unfortunately during covet families have
to be even more prepared for
those tough and uncomfortable
conversations like about
death and wills things of that nature
our law vegas now expert eric palacios
joined us to explain further
eric welcome back thank you for having
me
so we're talking about something people
don't like to talk about
wills um and my first question here is
you know who gets property
if someone dies and doesn't have a will
you're so right it's a topic that no one
feels comfortable uh talking about and a
lot of people are not prepared
uh when someone passes away and leaves
uh
belongings property without a will the
state decides
uh who gets your inheritance your
property in nevada
if you're married it goes all to your
spouse
if you don't have children if you do
have children uh then half goes to your
spouse
and the other half is divided amongst
your children
right but what if you don't have a
spouse or kids what happens then
that's the case for for a lot of folks
if that happens then
it'll go to your parents if your parents
are no longer alive
then it's divided amongst your siblings
and
what happens obviously wills get messy
in between family members and relatives
what happens when
more than one relative wants you know
the same thing
that's a problem you see a lot of the
properties of the belongings there's
always
you know the nice home or the nice car
uh or certain uh
jewelry or or memorabilia that everybody
wants
uh because of its value or because of
its significance
uh if there is no will then a lot of the
people
family members can fight over these
items and then it leads to additional
court costs and legal fees in a
long stretched out battle so it's nice
to avoid all this
with a simple will that's put in place
and
when should someone prepare a will
that's a great question a lot of people
don't think about it until they're in
their their 50s 60s or even older
but we never know what's going to happen
tomorrow as this year has clearly shown
us
so it's always a good idea to get it
done as soon as possible even if you're
in your 20s and your 30s
if you're married if you have a home if
you have
some assets it's always a good idea to
talk to an estate planning attorney
get a will in place maybe even a living
trust
all right or just call you and get the
answers that way
all right eric thank you so much always
great advice thank you for having me
all right for more information give eric
palacios and associates a call that
number is 702-444-7777
you can also visit their website at
ericpalacioslaw.com we'll be right back